[موسيقى]
ما كانت مرحله سهله لان نحن اخوتنا
الكويتيين تربطنا علاقات وديه
وقسم من افراد عائلتهم اصدقائنا فما يكون
من السهل علينا كعائله هذا القرار واتوقع
انه ما كان سهل على
الوالد نعم ما كانت مرحله سهله
احتلينا الكويت ما اقدر اجمل الكلمه
واستعمل كلمه اخرى واضحه هذه الاعلام
والعالم كلها شافها
اقطعوا في حقنا واخطانا في ح
وهذه ايضا تصير بين الاخوه
[موسيقى]
لكن الشيء اللي معلوم انه احنا كنا خارجين
من حرب ايران منتصرين وكان العراق قياده
والدي قياده الرئيس صدام البوابه الشرقيه
اللي تدافع عن الامه العربيه وعن اخوتنا
في منطقه الخليج العربي
وهم كانوا سعداء بهذا الدور
واخوتنا بالكويت قلدوا الوالد
وسام والى اخره يعني كانت علاقه طيبه
بالجميع
لكن اللي اللي يعني المعروف لجميع هذا ليس
سر يعني ارجع واقول لك الاسرار ما تطلع
مني وما راح تسمعها مني وحقيقه ما عندي
البلد ودخل بحاله اقتصاديه سيئه جدا اثر
الحروب
رغم انه يعني اخوتنا بالخليج العربي كانوا
الممول لهذا الحرب والداعم للعراق بس طوال
ثمان سنوات
الا انه ايضا خرج من الحرب
منهك القوى اقتصاديا
وفاقد الكثير من الشهداء حرب ايران كانت
حرب شرسه جدا خسرنا بها الكثير من الشهداء
فقد تكون هاي الجزئيه هي اللي يعني استفزت
الرئيس صدام
بعد ان التقوا بمؤتمر صار ببغداد بالتسعين
وكانت هي هذه المشكله اللي افرزت اتخاذ
هذا القرار
[موسيقى]